انا لست مستشارا في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بهذه الجمله اخلى محامي الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب مسؤوليته عن
اي منشورات لترامب فهل تخلى اقرب موظفي
الرئيس الامريكي عنه
يعرف عن ترامب احبه وعشقه لمواقع التواصل
التي لطالما استخدمها لايصال رسائله
الخاصه لخصومه
اخرها وجهت لشخص لم يكن خصما ولا منافسا
هو مدعي عاما هاتن الفن براك المسؤول عن
التحقيق في قضايا جنائيه ماليه تلاحق
ترامب اثناء حملته الانتخابيه عام 2016
قبل ايام صعد الرئيس الامريكي السابق من
لهجته واشار في منشور الله عبر منصته
للتواصل
الى موت ودمار محتملين اذا تم توجيه
الاتهام اليه في القضيه
سبقتها جمله من ردات الفعل للرئيس
الامريكي السابق عبر سلسله تغريدات له
اثار بعضها حفيظه مناصريه ودفعت اخرين
للتحذير من تداعياتها تحدث فيها ترامب عن
مزاعم اعتقاله
هنا نعود للسؤال عن تفسير تصريحات ابرز
شخص حاليا في قضيه ترامب الجنائيه محاميه
والمدافع عنه جو تاكوبينا انتقد منشورات
الرئيس الامريكي السابق على الانترنت ضد
مدعي منطقه
ووصفها بغير الحكيمه لكنه في الوقت نفسه
لم يتخلى عن موكله تماما بل اشار الى ان
ترامب لم ينشر تلك التهديدات بنفسه
اعتقد ان هذا كان منشورا غير حكيم وضعه
احد العاملين على وسائل التواصل وسرعان ما
حذفه عندما ادرك الخطاب والصوره المرفقه
به صرح ترامب ام لم يصرح ودين ام لم يدن
اذا كان هناك شيء واحد اصبح واضحا بشكل
متزايد بشان مستقبل ترامب الرئاسي لعام
2024 فهو ان هذه الحمله ستكون اكثر شراسه
من سابقتها
روان حمزه العربيه